[Musik]
an dc, um unseren Präsidenten
Donald Trump zu unterstützen, wir lieben ihn, wir werden alles
tun, was wir tun müssen, um ihn zu unterstützen
Ein Grund, warum ich heute
mit meinem Sohn hier bin, ist,
gegen den offensichtlichen Wahlbetrug zu protestieren
, der hinter unserem Rücken vor sich geht,
zum Beispiel
um 20 Uhr, äh, all die Swing-
Staaten, die sie nie aufgehört haben,
im Fernsehen auf Live-Heat zu zählen  ist in der
Geschichte passiert und dann wachst du
morgens auf
und die Stimmenflut für Trump plus
500 000 in Pennsylvania
um sieben Uhr am nächsten Morgen ist
plus 100 000
für Biden, das ist absolut unmöglich,
also kannst du mir eine davon nennen  Sie
zu einer Zeit,
warum sind Sie hier, um
unseren Präsidenten zu unterstützen?
Lieben Sie meinen Präsidenten. Sie haben meinen Rücken.
Ich habe seinen Rücken.
Was glauben Sie,
was hier heute
passieren wird
?  andere auf der Welt
und die Nachrichtenmedien tun dies  Ich rufe nicht zu
Wahlen auf, Amen,
es ist nicht vorbei, bis es vorbei ist, glaubst du
, Trump wird hier auftauchen,
er ist gleich um die Ecke,
sobald er zurück ist, geht er
durch
uns hindurch, wir lieben ihn mit unseren Körpern und unseren
Herzen und  unsere seelen
ich werde ihn mit meinem leben
[musik] projizieren
amen